and i just want to say it was awesome
how you stuck around met
people took pictures and [ __ ] i thought
that was really pretty awesome
i might even remember me i think i did
tell you that i was a pi listen to your
uh podcast
all the time because i'm in a car doing
surveillance driving all over virginia
oh yeah you're a pi
i remember you dude and i remember being
young they had
you know we had a dude i mean a pi first
of all when you hear it
i remember being young you hear a
private investigator
you think oh it's an animal you think oh
it's a um
gynecologist you know those are the
first two things i think
but then we had a dude in
the woods this guy detective mike and he
everybody said that he was private
investigator
well turned out he's just [ __ ]
homeless bro
he's peeping tom and this these have a
lot more peeping toms you'd see them you
know
comparing notes and [ __ ] you know
sharing ladders and all of that kind of
stuff sometime
you know down behind an amp superstore
down there off jackson avenue but
this was you know a time when when it
was more popular when people weren't
doing as much uh social media
so peeping time was a good way to you
know see who's hot in the area
it was kind of like tender but you had
to have a ladder
and this man uh was in the woods all the
time and we're like oh dude he's like
yeah i'm a detective i'm doing
surveillance
well for [ __ ] months we think he's
doing surveillance and [ __ ] and turns
out he's just a [ __ ] homeless dude
living in the woods man this dude
detective mike
and i guess i could i guess i can quit
calling him uh detective
because he wasn't you know he was
shooting dope evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one
watch this one